I want to know on a much more
philosophical level why we get into this
kind of situations
leaf you mentioned injustice and
intellectuals please explain what you
meant with that intellectuals are not
doing their jobs were mostly critics
we're not proposing inspiring solutions
we're talking too much we're listening
to little demonizing our fellow citizens
isn't working I am NOT going to call to
the barricades this Christmas I'm gonna
go back to Ohio where I grew up and I'm
gonna talk to the people in Ohio who
voted for Donald Trump I'm gonna listen
to what their concerns are
I suspect that their concerns are very
much like our concerns I suspect that
they feel that they have been humiliated
in the society and that they're not
getting a fair share from our rules they
see a corrupt corporate elite changing
the rules in the favor of those who are
already rich to make them richer and
they don't feel like they're members of
our society the world seems to be
ignoring the rise of a an animal that
has caused so much misery in the world
and that animal is called the dictator
dictators rise in this way they play on
people's fears and so on we have had
about the two world wars two
catastrophes at the center of it is an
animal called a dictator we have seen a
lot of wars civil wars in Africa in the
Middle East if you look closely it is on
the bed at the center of it is an animal
or an institution called a dictator a
dictator is not a dictator because the
country is called a dictatorship you can
have a dictator in a democracy for
example in the American system if we had
to follow exactly what mr. Trump once
also says once then we are in in in a
dictatorship which is coming so the
world must now start fighting the
dictator we have a dictator in Zimbabwe
in Africa and they have common
characteristics they come as liberators
they come is wanting to save the people
but underlying them is this big
self-interest Aida is a class interest
or as an individual interest so I think
we are in for a very very difficult time
and a more unjust world is coming I
think it's a very interesting question
which you raised before we started to
speak about RAM that was definite
oppression of justice that is how you
can make the society of merchants I
think it's that's very very interesting
say because the idea of a complete
disaster xiety is the worst ideas of
them or because completely just society
is a society where no one can say that
it isn't unjust that is completely just
society is a dictatorship in fact
because justice is not salt and sugar
which is contained in the Volta which is
the state it is when people believe that
this is just and it is just that all
these people who they say no it is
unjust that each institution is unjust
we argue for it and we want to change it
without this that is no liberal
democracy liver a democracy by
definition a society which is not never
entirely just and this is basically the
good in it that it's not entirely
justice that all these people can say
this is unjust this this institution
soldiers this is not good something
would be better you can always say that
would be better we can change we can
believe that it has to be changed and I
think this inspires in cleaver and
democracy is never completely just
society completely just society a
totally turned dictatorship I am sorry
I think there was a misunderstanding
I understood you I wonder too actually
about yourself I said I misunderstood
your position yeah yeah but we agree
thank you
the question if the question if I
understand it correctly is then about
current anxieties what's new Eunji
injustice is from time immemorial from
the time the hills were created and so
the question is really what happened now
that gives certain kind of urgency to
the anxiety one line is Simon's line
which is basically beautifully described
by Yeats the center doesn't hold the
best lack all conviction the worst are
full of passionate intensity so what the
best needs is intensity to counter the
intensity of the worst and the basic
thing here is really the feeling the
strong feeling that things are happening
we're in the midst of things that are
happening and we just don't understand
and the failure of the pollsters so
people are not embarrassed the same
people who explained to you a day before
the election that the election of
electing Trump is impossible
the day after explain to me why it was
necessary so the people that the people
are insane full when things we simply I
think at the basis of the anxiety and
it's growing because of division of
labor complicated technology complicated
a much more complicated world is in it
we live in a situation that we radically
don't understand my lesson from the last
from this election is not to join the
army of self
how to save the world but first start
with really understanding what's going
on before you change the world well I
couldn't agree more with you I wish I
but I I think actually it begins with
something from which our education say
essentially like many people around this
table I remember you know I too was I
was born in 1945 my history teachers but
actually I had a history teacher who
said to me when we were 11 years old
well boys we don't understand what the
rest of the 20th century happens but of
one thing we can be sure
institutionalize fanatical religion and
nationalism are things of the past so
much for the prophetic powers of history
teachers really but what we erase that
is because what we have is a very what
makes it quite difficult to understand
is that we have ancient demons and
hobgoblins ferociously in the emotive
power of nationalism of a kind of
visceral tribal tribal sense of
regeneration it's almost biological but
it's very very ancient that is being
wired together with the world that be
shaped by robotics by the cyber universe
by artificial intelligence so we have
wired together two things which the
Enlightenment assumptions about progress
don't allow for but nonetheless it's
absolutely the Golem ization of of
politics in in that way that we don't
yet really have a grip on what it is
that we must actually address ourselves
to other than you know it's clear that
the sociological analysis simply of
structural inequalities it's it's
absolutely right but it is not enough
and you raise the point of storytelling
very kindly to myself an alien from what
does strike me is that not just a kind
of intellectual view of the long
struggle for liberal democracy has has
not actually not actually been told with
enough narrative vigour and vividness
has not become you know part of the
American story right now but it but it
hasn't made its way into public
discourse by mean work by which I mean
this goes beyond the university beyond
wonderful conferences like that it's not
sexy it's not a university it's not a
it's not entertainment I mean I was
being only partly facetious when I
discussion we speak urban to 30
different places of the world from
Africa from Turkey from America that is
the question is what is common in them
because there's you know the differences
first example in America that will be no
totalitarian dictatorship because the
first step or totally dictatorship is to
change the constitution and if you
cannot change the constitution you
cannot have totalitarian dictatorship
now the fascist no voice changes or any
of this kind it's a different kind of
phenomenon Turk is a different kind of
phenomenon Hungary - there's something
in common between us and Poland eastern
part of Europe etc our question is what
is common and that's in common we are
modern or modern society that is
modernity a modern it is a world which
is as you indicated it has no foundation
it is based if I may say on freedom but
freedom is a foundation we just don't
want you are free to do anything it has
three different kind of tendencies one
tendencies mark a distribution which
sometimes called capitalism the others
technology progress integral the only
thing that is progress is technology
because it's come humiliation of
knowledge technical coming and the third
is the possibility to change political
rule that is choose the kind of
political rule you want to choose given
what human nature is all about will
history remain that tale told by an
idiot or
you didn't finish the question that well
will it run me or not well I think the
you know the telling of history is and
it's an attempt to escape from the
idiocy of the contemporary from the
prism of the contemporary and I'm the
person who said we have to really think
about now and I echo Avishai is concern
that we think about what's new but I've
always thought of history as a kind of
involuntary involuntary pluralism
because you're if you're doing it right
and this is true also the kind of kind
of writing that Elif does I think it's
it's involuntary empathy you have to put
yourself in other people's shoes
separated in space and time and for me
the great conundrum and the great
potential tragedy of our time as well is
that the world is divided as we've all
said in one way or another between those
who feel life must be lived with people
who look and sound exactly like
themselves and our coastal people who've
found that life is actually most rich
when it's living with people who are not
like ourselves and histories job really
is to win is to give narrative richness
to the possibility of a fully lived
human life being with others thank you
thank you so much
[Applause]
you